[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the dr
john dolone show is my co-host today as
we take your questions about your mental
wellness your boundaries your
relationships your money your career
your job your life right here on the
ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
spencer is with us in uh indiana to
start off this hour hey spencer what's
up
hey dave um i have quite a mess i've
made for myself
um but for what me and my wife are
working on trying to get out cool we're
on baby step two
and um
i have a whole bunch of student loans um
i haven't consolidated them yet
partly because of the the way that
the repayment is right now everything's
kind of on forbearance
i've been making the minimum payment
despite the forbearance but
my question is this
i have a car loan
that's about thirty thousand dollars and
i have a bunch of student loans well i
have some student loans that are less
than thirty thousand
but my payment for my car is about five
hundred dollars and
my payment for each of the student loans
are like
all together are about a thousand
dollars
and normally i
if i'm following your plan right i would
pay the smallest loans off first
but i'm just wondering if i'll have more
money to pay back with if i pay my car
off first
nope
works exactly the same math
math doesn't change
okay the um you're because
let's just pretend you're paying two
thousand dollars or three thousand
dollars a month on debt
okay
and then you're banking a a car payment
or you're not making a car payment
either one you're still going to plow
through the total of the debt in exactly
the same amount of time
it does not speed it up to get rid of
the big payment at all
the only thing that was speeded up is if
you got rid of a bigger interest rate
which is not what we teach but that
would actually speed it up
but paying but getting rid of the bigger
payment that you're making anyway
doesn't change a thing so what do you
guys make a year
um 3 20. well that's good
what do you do for a living
i'm a nurse anesthetist ah
and there's the student loans so yeah
what kind of mess did you make how much
is the student loan debt
right now it's at 275
that's a lot
what else what else
well i have uh we have one of our cars
is almost paid off we have about five
thousand left on it and then our other
car is about 30. okay that's it student
loans and cars
yeah well i mean we have a we have a
house we have a mortgage and we actually
have two houses one's getting rented out
but um
we only have our mortgage but that's the
rest of our what's that what's that how
the rental house worth
uh it's worth maybe 200. what do you owe
on
about that we just
it was real like i said it's kind of
messy so
i would go and get i would go and get
that sold
that's not a blessing that's a curse
well the reason i didn't sell it was
because i haven't had it for that long
i'm worried i'd pay a bunch of taxes on
it you're not paying taxes
you're not going to make any money okay
if you don't make money on it you don't
pay taxes
okay and was it a residence
yeah we we we were in it for just a few
months but how long have you been out
how long have you been out of it
uh about two months oh you can sell it
with no taxes at all
no matter what your profit is up to a
half million dollars married filing
jointly yeah you need to get rid of that
thing asap brother because it's it's uh
it's a vampire it is not going to do
anything except suck your blood
so you need to you need to be done with
that puppy and the um
and then from there
you know basically what we're dealing
with are the big numbers here
are we going to pay 150 a year on this
and be done in two years and have no
life
yeah and that's what i would
hope that's what i would prescribe
quit acting like you make a lot of money
and instead act like you're a broke
person because by the way you're a broke
person who actually
actually makes a lot of money
but uh uh which is wonderful great news
is you have a horrible hole that you're
in and you have a big old shovel to dig
out so that's wonderful
but i mean if you live on a hundred
thousand dollars a year and you put the
rest of it towards this day you could be
done in two years
what we're hoping yeah well it's not
home
last year i was
yeah last year i was making
130 i think yeah 140 yeah
so
all right spencer spencer and we can get
better
spencer yeah
i'm going to ask you two questions right
in a row and just answer yes or no did
you take out 275 000 student loans
yes okay cool period that conversation
is over i can feel i can hear you
walking around your head staring at the
ground
and you cannot get gazelle into a
gazelle can't run away with staring at
the at one foot in front of it because
it's going to trip and fall on its own
face hold your head up high you did it
it's over you own it and now we're going
to be about what comes next and now
you're a nurse anesthetist which makes a
butt load of money a ton of money
you you have people be alive yeah so now
go clean up the mess and in two years
you'll be done and you'll look back five
years from now with a big old pile of
money and you go god man
i almost busted it there thank god i
decided to yes you know lean into this
yeah so lean into it with a smile and go
be aggressive come on man game on get it
get it well i hope it just hope it works
no no it's not going to get it it's not
going to knock it down it's math it's
not i it's not a wish by god it's math i
mean you make two you make 320 000 let's
put 150 a year on 275 and in two years
it's magically gone you know i mean it's
this is how it works but i and i don't
really care what your nurse anesthetist
friends are doing because they're
mathematically stupid so don't listen to
them okay i really don't care if they're
buying houses or bmws or whatever sell
the stupid house you just moved out of
get rid of it it's a problem it's not a
blessing uh you can keep the cars just
because you make some stinking much
money if you want to keep that thirty
thousand dollar car it's okay if you're
going to get out of debt in two years or
less
if you're not going to get out of debt
in two years election you sell the 30
000 car
but you need to you you really you
really need to get out you need to get
this done
and you can do it
it's very
doable
now it's man i i i sometimes i talk to
people that have 275 000 in debt
and they make 100
or they make 65 and that that's a bigger
problem man i mean that's a little bitty
shovel in a big old hole you know you
can't you can't do that so
you know the good news is you have the
blessing of this income so you have to
dial it in and be
game on
committed you and your wife and go
we don't make 320 000 a year we're not
going to act like we make 320 000 a year
because we have a mess that is bigger
than this and we have to live on nothing
beans and rice rice and beans you don't
need to see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there you don't
need to go on vacation you need to get
out of debt and you can do it you can do
it you can do it i can see it
and i can't wait to hear your debt-free
scream it's going to be amazing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today people are craving connection
they're craving community they're
craving the energy that comes with
humans being with other humans
we hear you and we're the same way
around here and that's why we're
bringing back our life-changing
live events we're going back on the road
and we are not holding back this year uh
first up is wealth building live it's
coming to orlando on thursday may 19th
this thing is selling fast it's almost
sold out already you can still get
tickets though if you do it if you're
waiting around to buy your ticket don't
it's about gone this event is going to
is going on tour this year we're going
to have other locations to tell you
about really soon another one this
uh this spring it's a city that sounds
kind of like las vegas but we'll just
see it sounds suspiciously like that
when you say it but i'll let you know
when i have the contract signed that we
can actually go so
uh good stuff and four more cities in
the fall including in the are in
addition to that in the fall we're going
to be doing our uh
smart conference smart conference is
back it's a day-long conference where
you get smarter about every area of your
life all of the personalities will be
there rachel cruz dr john deloney ken
coleman george campbell christina ellis
pedro la torre
and our good friends craig and amy
groschel from life church are coming
they're going to be talking about
marriage we're going to be talking about
money we're going to be talking about
leadership we're going to be talking
about your mental wellness we're going
to be talking about
your career and your job every area of
your life by the time you get to the end
of the day you will be smarter
i promise you'll be tired too be a long
day it's gonna be a great day though
we're excited about it i haven't gotten
to do one of these in a couple of years
because of all the garbage going on out
there but october 22nd dallas if you
want to learn more about all of our live
events as they come online you can keep
up with them at ramseysolutions.com
events going to be good to be back on
stage doing these smart conferences
again john i can't wait can't wait can't
wait i've been on the road a lot the
last last few months and i can't wait to
get on but i've been by myself and
staying in hotels working with
businesses all across the country i
can't wait to get back on the road with
the gang yeah it's gonna be fun get the
band back together baby it's time all
right lynn is with us in minneapolis hi
lynn how are you
hi dave hi john thank you for taking my
call sure i am a huge huge fan thing and
i'm debt-free thanks to you and your
program
i am 60 years old i make 55 000 a year
as an administrative assistant and yet i
still have paycheck to paycheck because
of my high grant but i love where i live
my my take home pay is 2600 a month and
my rent is 16.55
which is over half of my take-home pay
for a one-bedroom apartment
i've been looking at purchasing a condo
but the ones i like get outbidded and
the older condos which are more
affordable to buy um have a high like
700 an hoa fees and i'm not comfortable
with that high of a key
so my question for you today is i really
like the convenience of renting
i'm wondering if it's in my best
interest to purchase something or if
it's okay to keep renting i i could find
a cheaper apartment that's not as nice
but it would be like two hundred dollars
less a month
okay and i'm your your 2600 number if
you make 50 000 is wrong
that's right yeah well 2600 is 30 000.
you don't have 20 thousand dollars in
taxes
do you make 50 a year is that what your
salary is based on are you getting a
hundred are you getting a huge refund or
are you counting stuff that's coming out
of your check other than taxes when
you're telling me what your take-home
pay is
oh i'm current like that's like what it
comes out from my benefits and my
retirement okay how much are you putting
in how much are you putting in
retirement
okay i do
i i do four percent which is required
for an eight percent match
and then i do another one percent on top
of that so that comes to 28 57 a year
okay your benefits expensive
are you getting it are you getting a big
tax refund every year
i'm i'm not because i also get fossil
support and i have to pay taxes on that
okay
so i just i just keep i don't i just
keep out what i need for taxes and and i
got [ __ ] really big this year for some
reason now i'm still struggling with how
we go from a 50 000 income to a 30 000
take-home pay
i'm trying to find where that money is
going okay and it didn't go to
retirement if they're like
my paychecks are like 1384 and i get
paid well maybe that's and i do get paid
26 times a year token well that's a
little bit better um
about 35 000 at this point but still
there's something there's still some
money
i mean i'm not saying it's missing i
just don't know where you're what you're
doing with it exactly so
okay the answer to your question in in
overall without trying to figure out
what to do today about it
is that if you're 60 for the next 30
years can you imagine what rents are
going to do
yeah that that scares me because they
they i had an increase one year of 150 a
month yeah and it's like it that's the
problem with being a renter in
perpetuation
is is the largest portion of your
income goes to housing and you lose
control
of how much it increases
when you are at the mercy of the
landlord
and so you don't want to be a renter for
the next 30 years because that's gonna
you know it's gonna increase versus if
you bought that condo you know you've
locked in what it costs you not counting
the hoa fees but you've locked in your
cost per month for the next 30 years
and so i'm moving in some way towards
one of these condos and some method
figuring out how i'm going to get there
and what have i got to do to cause that
to happen because that's a better
long-term
play for you
we also know that the folks that reach
you know they reach a million dollar net
worth the vast majority of them well
over 80 percent of them
the primary source of their wealth is
two things they're retirement plans
and they're paid for house
and so you know if you end up with a 700
000 800 000 net worth
uh you know in in 10 or 15 years over
time here uh which you probably could do
uh a portion of that a third of that a
uh
two half of that or whatever would be
you're paid for condo that you got paid
off in the next 15 years so i want that
stability in your long term plan
that's why we don't want to be a renter
long term but it doesn't mean we're
stupid in the short term and you go out
there in the name of not renting anymore
you go do something foolish and buy
something you can't afford yeah
which is what a lot of young couples do
when they get married they have to rush
out and buy a house that they can't
afford or you get in a bidding war and
suddenly you're yeah i don't think she
was very wise to walk away from those
bidding wars she said it went up and i i
tapped out
and that's very very smart
michael is in pasadena california hey
michael what's
how's it up thank you for taking my call
um dr john and they appreciate you both
sure how can we help
yeah so we're in a little bit of a
situation i i'll give you the briefest
uh
the briefest uh
when explanation that i can so basically
my wife and i we live in in california
currently
um we're actually building a house in
arizona that's where we're from uh so
we're building a brand new build
we have money from the previous bill of
our house
before we moved here we have the cash in
our account
we can pay off all of our student loans
and uh potentially have a little bit in
savings before we go back to phoenix
good so we're trying to figure out if we
should keep the
cash or pay down all of our debt like
really aggressively i'd be debt free by
the end of the day
okay
now does how are you going to close on
the new build if you don't have any cash
so that's the thing we have cash now we
have like i know i just got rid of all
your cash how are you going you i
offered that as an option how are you
planning on closing on the new build
um well we have a little bit of cash but
it won't be it won't be as much because
we have to pay we have to pay some money
up front
um just to get the process started
because then you can yeah i want you to
put as
say hold out just enough to close on the
new build barely
and hold out
a little bit of an emergency fund and
then i want you to throw the rest of it
at this debt and move to arizona
debt-free into a new house it's gonna
change your whole attitude about
everything when you do that
it sounds reckless and crazy but you're
gonna be free
and that's what i would do today this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr john doloni ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage stephen
and kaylee are with us hey guys how are
you wonderful thank you for having us
dave
honored to have you where do you guys
live grand rapids michigan oh we love
grand rapids welcome to nashville good
to have you and how much debt have you
paid off 231
000 and some change way to go
and how long did this take you 25 months
wow you're kicking it and your range of
income during that time
we started around 190 and finished
around 260. goodness what do you guys do
for a living i'm a physician assistant
and i'm in dental sales oh both wow okay
that's ringing the bell on the income
well done so i'm gonna guess and say uh
231 might be a bunch of student loans
for the pa
both of us both of you yeah all right
all right very cool yep um student loans
and we both had car loans and
credit cards yeah i literally i i lived
in my mid-20s like uh she was looking at
him well he looked at her for student
loans and she got him back with the
credit cards oh that's good same team
right you got to trade you got to trade
the look back and forth there it was
pretty good yeah that's good okay how
long y'all been married
just six five months oh my gosh yeah so
you started you started this separately
and then combined it and knocked it out
so yeah we're
a little different where we
i mean i'll let kaylee tell the story
and how we get so we started this just
while we were dating um
we i remember i was sitting at a wedding
and like looking around and i was like
one day we'll probably want to get
married how are we ever going to afford
this
um
and i was
i remembered hearing your name a little
bit growing up and i googled dave ramsey
and saw the total money makeover you're
sitting at a wedding and you googled it
i was just going through my goodness eat
the cake
okay but the wedding woke you up then
when you got home you googled it yeah
okay and um so saw a total money
makeover and steven picked it up for me
at uh barnes noble and i read it the
following weekend and
probably within the next month kind of
slowly decided to pay off my car and
tell him about it a little bit and
then we both kind of really got on board
um but we did
it was interesting because we were just
dating we weren't even engaged at the
time and we both were doing our own debt
snowballs
so it was kind of unique in that way
yeah so i bought her that book and
watched her just get after it
and i had my own i guess you can you can
say i was davish um paying off like
trying to aggressively pay off my credit
cards but then i saw how aggressive she
was being with her car and i was like
i want to marry this woman i got it i i
gotta either i'm gonna either have to be
all in or all out and i decided to be
yeah you just can't be left in the dust
here you got to keep up i mean come on
i started aggressively getting after it
and then i looked over
she was actually aggressively kidding me
he was much more aggressive than i was
so
you had two cars at the time and yeah
yeah i had a work vehicle and a regular
vehicle and i was like
dave would not love that
and uh so i i sold my work vehicle and
used my personal vehicle as both work
and personal and um started the debt
snowball from there yeah
way to go you guys this is amazing i
mean once you decided to do it both of
you were just you knocked it down big
time yeah and so in the middle of this
debt is also your cash flow wedding too
yep we cash flowed about two-thirds of
our wedding yeah um and it wasn't just
our jobs we had a lot of we had a lot of
side gigs
she picked up uh shifts in urgent care
she made a ton of money that's the
lucrative thing yeah yeah picking up um
other people's garbage and refurbishing
it and selling it on facebook
marketplace oh
wow okay um and i have a little side
lawn mowing business in the summer
so yeah that we we definitely uh worked
a lot more than we played yeah i'm sure
yeah but you're free
yeah and we were able to pay both of us
pay our debt off
the week by the week before our wedding
correct oh okay yeah oh so that was your
finish line goal we wanted we want to
marry each other debt-free well it
wasn't initially though when you talk
about this on the show a lot like we
thought it would maybe be
we thought that she'd inherit a little
bit of my debt and it'd be about five
months after the wedding six months
prior to the wedding um and even though
we were doing it separately we felt like
we were doing it together yeah you know
constant communication with each other
accountable and encouraging and
encouraging and um we looked at
competitive yeah
yeah she won
she always will my brother i know get
used to that yeah so five months before
the wedding we're like wow we can if we
if we put our heads down this summer we
can we can do this before the wedding
and the weekend before we got married
we uh we paid it all off i love it wow
that's amazing thank you well done you
guys very well done
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
constant communication
and just being there for each other
because we are unique we weren't married
yet we attacked our snowballs separately
but it didn't feel like that because we
were constantly going over our budget
holding each other accountable to our
budget i mean she took me who in my
mid-20s would take my tax return and go
to nashville and blow it all when i had
a ton of debt so the irony is you're in
nashville
so uh holding each other accountable and
continuously having that that open
communication
and uh being on the same page being on
the same page
what's the best uh boyfriend girlfriend
disagreement you had over the budgets
um i would say
when she i i know what you're going to
say the vehicles oh no no
um this is the newlywed game right yeah
answer very carefully stephen for me
when she was being very aggressive at
paying off her vehicle and i was like
why did i get her that book um
i was when she that's when she kind of
came to me and was like you know you
should definitely think about this too
you have two vehicles and
i i remember kind of fighting her on
that for a while just because
that's just the way i had lived
throughout my 20s
um what was
oh
in my mind it was kind of our like
stephen was saying we would sit down and
budget
every week probably and
our
i would
underestimate i guess
the budget and i would um he would
always say you probably need just a
little bit more money for that and so we
would that would just be like a week a
weekly thing where where we would kind
of have different mindsets on things so
now that we're married and that we make
our budget together that was an
adjustment as well
like we just have different minds on
things you guys talk about savers and
spenders
um and just probably having little
disagreements about you're probably
going to pay a little bit more for
groceries than that this week and i'm
like no i can probably get by
um two dollars is enough
weeks were like 25 had it had to get us
through for groceries yeah that's not
yeah yeah
i don't think that's gonna work yeah no
but now you all make a bunch of money
and you have to keep all of it yeah
cool man it's it's fun we uh
we went to new york around christmas
we're here this weekend yeah didn't feel
bad about spending nine dollars on a
beer on broadway like i used to
and uh it's more than that it wasn't it
wasn't financed you paid for it today
instead of four months from now so
congratulations and because we had just
gotten done paying off a debt we really
didn't go on a real honeymoon so we're
going to italy in a month
i love it
good for you guys well i'm proud of you
thank you you did very well who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you outside the two of us um my
parents were really big supporters both
of them cheered us on along the way
yeah my parents have always been there
all the way to support me with whatever
i choose to do
we have a we have my college roommate um
and good friend him and his wife live in
lansing michigan nick and rachel they're
um they're in the journey with us so it
was fun
yeah they're recently debt-free too so
um having like people our age getting
after it with us along the same and you
know hanging out with them and talking
about the frustrations of it all uh it
really helped yeah
way to go guys
way to go we're proud of you well done
well done we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you because that's the
next chapter baby that's the next
chapter in this story making 260. you
ought to be there in 20 minutes i mean
it shouldn't shouldn't take long at all
you got no payments life is good how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too
231 thousand dollars paid off in 25
months did it separately and together
sort of by communicating 190 to 260
income count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
yes
well done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five
five two two five zack is with us in
oklahoma city hey zach how are you
[Music]
i am uh doing all right i guess
okay cool how can we help
uh
well this is where the i guess part
comes in it looks like about a 90 chance
that i'm gonna end up divorced here soon
and i'm
trying to figure uh hoping uh dr john
can help with some advice on how to just
kind of stay focused because this is
screwing with me a little bit and i'm
not doing performing well at work and
stuff
so are you asking about
the
okay so back me out here you said about
90 and then i i got sidetracked here so
i'm assuming you you're not into this
this isn't your idea
nope
okay so what happened
um
the short version is that she struggles
with borderline personality disorder and
does not believe that she needs help and
she has just started making a bunch of
ridiculous impulse decisions and then
blaming me for the fact that nothing is
working out and that we can't afford the
marriage counseling and stuff that we
need and she just finally dipped out
okay
so
um you say there's 10 percent chance
that this isn't going to happen is that
a realistic percentage or is that you
just hanging on to hope
the latter okay has is there attorneys
involved yet has she filed on you
she's not filed anything
if i'm being truthful i bet that if this
goes through i'll probably end up having
to pay for it when i finally get sick
away and just decide to move on myself
but
all right so in this situation here's
the person you can deal with you
and i can hear the bitterness
dripping from your language which i
don't i don't i don't blame you i'd be
bitter too i'd be frustrated and sad and
upset and all that
but that is clouding all of your
judgment all of your decisions all the
words that come out of your mouth all
the thoughts in your head your inability
to get up and go for a walk or a run in
the morning your work performance
everything
okay
so
you tell me you can't afford to go talk
to somebody i'm telling you you can't
afford not to
figure it out
okay
call some friends or call a pastor call
i'm not talking about her i'm talking
about you
okay
this isn't about her right now this is
about you because you can't control what
she's doing and she stepped out on you
okay
do you hear what i'm saying
yeah i know what you mean and i
apologize if i started through this that
happens when i get frustrated with
situations like this
what i was trying to say is like she is
she was the reckless spender in our
relationship i kept trying to wiggle
between trying to budget for all of the
help that we needed while trying to keep
her happy with the impulse purchases she
wanted to make and i'm going to go see
somebody because it sounds kind of bad
but now that she's walked out i can
afford to do so because i don't have to
spend on her recklessly hold on hold on
hold on i just told you
stop talking about her and you
immediately came back and started
blaming her for other stuff
i'm i am sorry no don't be sorry just
listen to how much this has poisoned
your heart
okay
and the only thing on planet earth you
can control
is your thoughts and your actions and
that's it
and that is
a powerless helpless feeling in these
moments when someone you love has said i
don't love you anymore i'm out of here
it's heartbreaking it's devastating
and yet the only thing you can control
is your thoughts and your actions so i'd
make a phone call today
and say i'm not okay
every minute of my life is venom and
poison towards my wife she's leaving me
and i'm not okay anymore and i'm using
anger and rage and all these other tools
to try to prop myself up through this
heartbreak and i need to look somebody
in the eye and say i'm not okay
that's what i mean
and so
the language that you used like when we
started talking about the um
you can afford counseling you circled
back and said well now that she's out of
the way
you see what i'm doing instead of just
going yeah i've actually got the money
now
there's two different sets of language
saying the exact same thing
and uh but that's just due to that's
just your pain you can we can hear the
pain in your word choices
and even in your voice tone um and so
and that's what's throwing you because
i'm gonna guess john that uh
if i were in this situation i know what
i would be doing uh if i were losing
focus it would be because all i'm doing
is replaying all of these tapes in my
head over and over and i should have
said and what if i'd have done this and
i could have done that and then if she'd
done that and i'd said that and uh all
these ruminations all these things
you're never really gonna do these
conversations you plan out they're never
going to happen that's right and you
ruminate on them and play on them and
play on them and play on them and play
on them and play on them and all of a
sudden the car's driving down the
shoulder instead of the middle of the
road that's exactly right and you hear
the warning track and you go wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute i'm
i'm not even driving
and so zack
real quick now that dave mentioned it i
forgot one of the main reasons why i
wanted to call and ask about this i
drive a truck for a living i'm alone for
three to four weeks at a time
okay that's part of why i think this
anger has caused me problems the way i
realized
yeah that makes sense and and i know
enough about bipolar that a gap missing
another person
can be devastating to that so i bet if
she was to call she might be saying hey
i've been missing my husband
for months at a time for years over year
over year and why do i tell you that
most of the time in these situations
unless there's just an out-of-control
abuse situation
more everybody's playing a role and so
this vitriol this anger this rage all
you're doing is poisoning yourself
hoping she it rubs off on her and it's
not it's killing you
so breathe it out man stop having these
imaginary conversations with her and go
talk to somebody and if you can't afford
a counselor because people are listening
and going i can't be nice
find a couple of friends it goes back to
that it demands a witness your
heartbreak and your grief and your
sadness you got to have other people you
can say hey i'm not okay with
and i don't need your advice i need you
just to say man i'm so sorry i'll get
the next round yeah as far as the money
thing goes until you get through this
process you're probably not going to
make any traction
on your finances
because um you know it's expensive it's
distracting and so you're in the middle
of a hurricane and when you're in the
middle of a hurricane you don't work the
total money make over baby steps yeah
you you push pause and you pile up cash
to get through the hurricane then when
the hurricane goes by
and it's over then we assess the damage
and we start rebuilding from there we
push play again we start working the
baby steps and that's how you're gonna
do that as far as your finances go
trevor is in salt lake city hi trevor
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi dr john thank you for taking
the call i'll try and give you a quick
download here um
my wife and i are in baby step seven um
and i just found out
yesterday that the company i've been
working for for eight years is
going to be closing down the division
that i work in in the next uh 12 to 18
months cool what do you do for a living
i work in manufacturing what do you do
for dental products i'm a manager
you're a manufacturing manager okay what
do you make yes
uh dental products
how much money do you make
oh sorry 85 000 a year okay cool this
opportunity for you get a better job
yeah
so the company is shutting down the
division that i work in um they are
trying to reabsorb some of the people
into other divisions of the company um i
like the company it's got a great
culture and i and i want to stay there
my question is
is should i just continue
kind of doing what i've been doing with
my finances or should i
go into sort of a storm mode and just
kind of save up some cash until i know
things are stable again what would your
advice be
well i think i would go get my new job
yeah
and i never skip a beat okay
all right at least be having
conversations all over the place no i
mean go get a job making 110 yeah and
leave tomorrow
as soon as you get that job okay
why are you gonna why you don't you
don't you don't need to stay on the
titanic as it goes down there's no this
doesn't do anything for you it's not
your boat
so you wouldn't look at moving to other
departments within the company unless it
paid more
okay i wouldn't take a pay cut to stay
with them they're they're not healthy
they're not doing well or if you were if
you were a aim a player they would have
said hey we're closing the division but
you we're having a meeting with you
because we're making sure exactly that
would have happened it didn't happen
yeah human nature is that this thing
always ends up with a pay cut
and i have often seen it when you decide
otherwise ending up a pay increase
but you need to decide otherwise and
start planning now don't wait on this to
sneak up on you they've already told you
it's coming
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your mental wellness we
talk about your relationships your job
your career your money in your life the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
deanna is with us in knoxville to start
this hour off hi deanna how are you
i'm doing all right i'm tickled to be on
the show with you guys well we're
honored to have you how can we help
so my husband and i have been handed a
pickle
he's been he's being sued for a debt
that he co-signed with his now ex-wife
and she was supposed to refinance it as
part of their divorce she never did
now they're coming to him for it
we understand legally there's there's
not a lot we can do i mean he did sign
for it
but we were wondering if there was there
was anything negotiating just anything
that we don't have to pay the full the
full bet
what is this
on it was if i understand everything
correctly it was a car that was repoed
oh that's wonderful how long ago was the
car i know it was great
um i think
probably six years back we've been
married for three and it was at least a
couple years before then if i understand
it
the repo was
while they were still married
yes okay so they they had they owned a
car together and their car got repo'ed
okay yeah he he's he co-signed a car for
her oh he didn't co-sign his wife they
bought a car together
he just bought a car in his car right
here yeah and his car got repo'ed it
happened to be the one she drove but he
got repo'ed while he was married before
and now and the repo was six years ago
if i understand the timeline it's kind
of blurry to me obviously this is all
before we got together and got married
um did he just hope this was gonna go
away
uh it was something that he was supposed
to take care of in the divorce so it was
and of course she up and disappeared
last we heard she's somewhere in
nebraska running from her debt so
it's working
watch out nebraska look out nebraska
here she comes the uh
uh
okay so did you actually get served
lawsuit papers
and it was sent to um his old house that
we had sold to his daughter his daughter
let us know what what is it
a letter or are they uh yeah from from
the sheriff i'm assuming it is
well
i'm not assuming anything that's what
i'm trying to figure out do you have the
paper in front of you
i i don't uh he has pictures of it on
his phone it was when he sent us we live
in tennessee he's from indiana so this
is
all over the country right now okay all
right
all right so let's just stop a second
okay number one i doubt you've actually
been sued
he he might have gotten a notice saying
they were going to send something to the
sheriff but if they were going to sue
him
from a six-year-old
repossession deficit they would have
done it a long time ago
it's very unusual to get sued on a
six-year-old house
okay well it's possible they did it's
possible someone sold this debt okay so
either way here's what's going to go
down okay you get in touch with the
holder of the debt
um
one of two things has happened either it
is the original holder of the debt
or they have sold the bad debt to a bad
debt buyer
there are people there are companies
that buy old bad debt
and then try to collect on it and they
usually pla pay around a nickel on the
dollar
for it do you have any idea how much
money they're asking for
uh the paperwork that was sent initially
said eight grand when he called them
yesterday they said 12 on the phone and
i said oh hell no we're not doing we're
not doing any we're not doing any of
this
okay right
so here and here because here's the
thing let's just say it's ten thousand
dollars they probably paid five hundred
dollars for this debt if they bought it
okay that's what they got in it so
anything they get above 500 is a profit
for them
okay right now the uh
it's very difficult to collect a debt
across state lines
okay for them to execute service on you
in tennessee and actually start getting
money from you
using a lawsuit to do that is is very
expensive for them so they're not going
to do it
the probability is very high they're not
going to do it so this is all about
posturing
and bullying the schoolyard tactics not
about legal realities okay so they
either paid around 500 for this debt
or they're the original holder and just
put put those shoes on for a second it's
been six years
if someone owes you money for six years
anything you could get out of them you
would call yourself having one right
right all of this translates to you can
settle this for around 20 cents on the
dollar it's gonna cost you two grand
okay
i can breathe with that yeah and so call
them and offer them
seventeen hundred and forty three
dollars
as settlement in full and tell them
that's your calculation as to what his
part actually is after all these years
and that's what we're able to do any
more than that and we're just we don't
want to talk to you go ahead and sue and
do whatever it is you want to do because
we're not going to pay it
okay and with all of that between the
two of us he's he's a lot more
easy going about it i'm more of the
bulldog do i it's not they won't talk to
you you're not on the debt that's what i
wanted that's why i want to make sure
he's going to have to wear big boy pants
so you're going to have to like
pull his hair or
twist his ear or something and get him a
little riled up before he calls them
i can do that i can do that and deanna i
want to challenge something from this
point forward okay
yeah the world did not hand y'all a
pickle
you spoke as though this like hail hail
storm sat over your house
this is your husband signed up for this
and we understand that okay so yeah this
is y'all's moving forward yeah okay so
let's change the let's change the time
this is mr easy going didn't take care
of business
yeah
this was before he knew better we went
yeah i don't know
so i can't be mad at him yes you can
clean up yes you can i'm mad at him but
we have a mess together
yeah you go okay that's good so yeah so
get him riled up and here's the thing
okay
start at 1743 you're gonna settle
somewhere a little over two thousand
dollars give or take they will take that
it's going to take go ahead and count
them uh between five and ten arguments
they're not conversations they're
arguments
okay because you're dealing with an
idiot in a cubicle 500 miles away who
has a really horrible job cleaning
septic tanks is better than collecting
on old debt
that's fair okay he he's he really talks
nasty to people all day long and then
has to go home
and kiss his children with that same
mouth it's awful and so that's the guy
you're talking to and so you have to
argue with this guy five to ten
different times and it will land between
1743 start with that number and it'll
land above 2000 get it in writing before
you send the money in writing and
writing in writing or don't give them
any money that they accept that as
settlement in full
and then do not give them electronic
access to your checking account send
them a prepaid debit card or a wire do
not give them electronic access to the
checking account and get it in writing
five to ten conversations this is an
argument go
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
um
[Music]
john deloney's new book dr john loney is
my co-host today here on the ramsey show
his new book own your past change your
futures on pre-sale right now for just
20 bucks and john you took your two phds
your 20 years of counseling experience
and packed it into
a book that basically allows people to
feel like they're sitting across the
table from you yeah that's probably the
most common question to get is do you do
private therapy or would you be our
coach or personal family coach or
something i can't do that but if i was
to sit down with somebody and walk them
through where they are to where they
could be this would be it right this
would be the conversations we would have
yeah
own your past
change your future uh it's having a
positive impact on everybody everybody
who reads it it's all about mental
wellness
and uh everybody needs a little more
mental wellness including the two guys
sitting here so the single 30 year old
is looking to sharpen their mind the 25
year olds who's out of college and
trying to learn how to make better
friends new friends the mom who wants to
connect to her kids better uh people
dealing with anxiety people dealing with
abusive relationships people dealing
with just simple boundaries the
interfering mother-in-law
everyone
has a story
and we gave out advanced copies of the
book to some listeners they're going
crazy about it this book has been
absolutely life-changing for everyone
that's read it including me i i it was
it's a it's an amazing amazing read
uh we've taught god and grandma's ways
of handling money around here for 30
years at ramsey and now john is doing
that for mental
uh wellness
and for relationships it's a complex
topic
and he's put the put the cookies on a
shelf where we can all reach them i
pre-order your copy right now at
ramseysolutions.com for 20.
it is own your past change your future
for the twenty dollars in pre-order you
will get
the audio book version the e-book
version and a month of free
weekly therapy sessions from the folks
at better help
that's a bargain all for 20 bucks that's
pretty serious right there pretty good
and this book is selling guys like crazy
it's going to be our next number one
bestseller here at ramsey uh it actually
comes out in april so just a couple of
weeks from now we'll be mailing them out
to you guys
and uh actually be doing the big launch
day and everything official launch day
but it is on pre-sale and that's where
you get the bargains is when you order
it on pre-sale own your past change your
future you
you have to read this book it's an
absolute must john's been a lot of fun
on this project yeah it's the
i don't know writing a book would be
what i classify as fun but it's
definitely been a process right it's
like going to having surgery and uh but
yeah now it's now it's out out here hey
one of the coolest things of the
feedback i got to sit down and speak to
some of the folks who've been through
the who read it and tell me what they
thought directly
the most that every single person the
most common thing they say is
it's the first book that i've read in a
while that wasn't written at me it was
with me i felt like we were on this
thing together
and when i sat down to write this man
i've just read a thousand articles and
books that are experts talking at me
and the whole goal was to say no no
we're all in this thing man we're gonna
sit down let's do this together cause
i'm walking this thing through with my
little kids and my wife and my job and
my
and so we nailed it man just it's just
me walking alongside folks i'm excited
that's fun that's the way it should be
jordan is with us jordan's in san
antonio hi jordan welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thank you and appreciate all you guys
do help change the world appreciate it
all you too brother how can we
um
help
i'm basically just an underperforming
franchise owner a really small franchise
and i just kind of look and see what
ideas you guys have for someone who
sucks at being a salesman selling a
product that um
it's higher premium price i refinish
stores for standard starting price 850
and it's a two-week process for me it's
a real marine grade finish
but in my market in san antonio there's
a lot of cheap flavor who will do the
door in one day for like 150 200 bucks
so i'm struggling to make sales and and
just do my part and not be able to pay
my bills so
uh they had to go get eight to five jobs
so just wondering and i need to get kane
coleman's book but i'm studying
coordination but once i finish that i'm
gonna get his book so i just want to
know what you guys have to help me
become a better salesman so my business
can be what it needs to be
you're finishing what
finishing doors so like your wooden
mahogany oak your major entrances where
you're going to be paying like 30 000 if
you wanted to replace something normally
so a mahogany front door on a home is
that what you're talking about yes sir
yes sir and you refinish that for
dollars
starting yes sir okay
all right
and so this is obviously a product for
high-end neighborhoods only
yes yeah okay
and i suspect and you know having been
to san antonio a bunch of times there's
a lot of very nice homes there
i really wasn't aware there were a lot
of thirty thousand dollar front doors
no i hear you um it's definitely during
the territory purchase i had to look
through and
go through zip codes with that they most
likely had it so
um
i have zip codes that have that's
closest to my area that that i'm
targeting but i'm basically the only one
here so i actually kind of have the free
reign of the whole san antonio area for
now
yeah i get that um
i mean but i live in a home that's
several million dollars and uh the door
the front door didn't cost 850
probably yeah i understand that um it
was born out of cincinnati when there
you have homes where like the entire
front entrance it would cost them tens
of thousands to replace things and so i
just bought into it thought it was
pretty novel concept and i've actually
i've got some some jobs you know i've
landed some businesses how many
franchisees does this franchise over
have across the nation
uh i think currently around 10 it's
pretty pretty new yeah
okay
well i guess i'm gonna try to find uh
the top three and go visit with them
and ask them what they're doing that
you're not doing
because you have a very unique very
narrow very niche market and finding the
potential customer is probably half the
battle
and then once you've found them
convincing them
but dude if i've got a if i've got an ex
super expensive
imported italian
mexican whatever
uh something that i've brought in from
guadalajara and it's across the whole
front of my house spending 850 bucks on
it is nothing
uh but i just don't know how many of
those they are there are and how to find
them i
i'm not i'm not doubting that they're
there i just don't know how to answer
that part of the question but it sounds
to me like that that you know line
aligning yourself with the potential
customers
is the biggest thing
you don't need to sell firewood to
somebody doesn't have a fireplace you
know i mean it's just so finding
somebody that actually has the type of
product and
i i this is definitely not something
that's on every corner it's an ultra
high-end house and i would ask the
question
is this what do you want to be doing
art did you buy into something you
thought it would be cool you thought
they they just gave you a bill of goods
by how much money you were going to make
your year or two in you realize this
ain't fun i'm not making this money it's
not fun the way i keep getting up every
day is because i
i absolutely love my job
even the crummy parts of it i like the
thing dave gets up every day is like
he's got this mom in his head that he
says i've got to get up here today so i
can go help her there's a there's an in
there's a drive that is about serving
other people i don't hear that in you at
all my brother i hear well how do i just
keep this thing that i don't even like
it i don't know i'm doing it i'm good at
it how do i keep this thing alive
man there's the sunk cost thing i at
some point i said you walk away and get
a job that you like
or another business another business
whatever it is something that you're
fired up about
but if you if you are in love with this
and you do want to pursue it and you
really really
what you've got to find is someone who
is good at it and find out what they do
it's studying best practices
so i've got a friend in the real estate
in the radio business that contacted me
the other day
and uh they're coming in three or four
of them with their team to spend a half
a day with my team to see what we're
doing they're going to study us because
they want to have some of the success
level that we have had and we're going
to openly share and not charge them a
dime they're just a friend they're
coming over and hanging out and but
they're going to walk through here with
yellow pad notes and ask 5 million
questions and go home inspired to do
everything do things better do things
different than they were doing before
and that's what you need to do you need
to be that guy contacting one of these
other franchisees and going hey uh i'm
dying down here could i come spend a day
with you and take a vacation day from
your eight to five and go up there and
do that and uh if you're gonna pursue it
that's what you're gonna have to do
because i really can't tell you how to
find
people with
front doors expensive enough that they
want to spend 850 redoing the
door yeah
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage joe and
kelly are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you good welcome where do
you guys live
in new york from nico where miko it's up
in the adirondacks oh wow beautiful area
well welcome to nashville good to have
you down here all the way down here to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off
178 000.
how long did that take 19 months wow and
your range of income during that time uh
we started about 260 000 and got to 300
by the end wow what do y'all do for a
living
i'm a nurse anesthetist of course okay
i'm a mom and just started going back to
school good for you what are you
studying
counseling oh good good i like that
that's fun all right what kind of debt
was the 178 thousand uh
yeah we were living the great american
nightmare uh so we had a little bit of
student loan debt left uh caught two
cars that we uh owed a lot on
um we had a pool a boiler a boiler and
lots of credit cards yes
for those of us in the south what is a
boiler
[Laughter]
yeah up north is a fancy furnace
oh okay
i thought it was something you put your
wontons in for dinner so that's a
helpful clue
well you could but yeah it would be
dangerous
not a good idea
not a good plan well welcome guys that's
amazing good job so that was a that was
a pretty intense 19 months yes it was
yeah big change in the dutch family big
time so what happened tell me the story
you tell your awesome story first so
this is embarrassing uh
i was working a side hustle at a
hospital on a weekend so it's a saturday
i go downstairs to get lunch uh i was
driving a beautiful mercedes e63s at the
time one of the fastest four-door cars
in the world yes it is and uh i went to
buy lunch and when i gave him my debit
card it was denied i said oh that's no
big deal i'll just use my credit card
right well my credit card was maxed out
and so i'm standing there i have people
i work with behind me offering to pay
for my lunch and i in that moment i just
wanted to stand up on top of the
register counter and say i'm not poor
like i drive a mercedes but the reality
was we were i didn't have money in my
account and uh i did not want to live
that way anymore wow yeah i had just
paid something big off and drained our
entire account and so he had texted me
and was like what is going on i'm like
oh no i can fix it i can fix it he's
like we can't fix this this is this is a
problem so i feel like that was when we
hit rock bottom and it was like
we were living a lie yeah we were not
living there something about being
embarrassed and shamed yeah yeah i wrote
that in the first uh financial peace
book that we did
standing in the cold trying to get a
credit card to work driving a jaguar to
fill it i couldn't end the money put gas
in the car driving a jaguar yeah just
how dumb i was yeah but there's
something about that where you go uh-uh
right this is wrong
i'm done yeah so a lot of people get
that have that moment and they rage and
blame everybody else what what took you
to the mirror
i knew it was my fault uh i had done a
decent job with uh
our retirement and i knew how money
worked i just
i had always been taught that you know
that was something that you leveraged to
your advantage and
i didn't want to die i was so
embarrassed of dying and someone come
look at my finances and be like how did
you screw this up so bad
we would go on trips together and before
we left i would have a panic attack if
we died someone would look at our
finances and then we'd come home we
lived we just go back to life and then
we'd go on a trip again i'd freak out
then people are gonna look at our
finances so it was like if we needed
your mother telling you to wear clean
underwear
yeah just in case yeah
so yeah i feel like we had who we are we
had to hit rock bottom to like
like for the holy spirit but it really
it really wasn't it really wasn't rock
bottom in that in the sense that like
there was no foreclosure or bankruptcy
but it was just this emotional thing it
just smacked you in the face yes yeah
yeah that's true and he's worked so hard
and made
decent money and i feel like we should
just
make it like really good money yeah i we
saw it after we started like not having
so much debt i was like wow you're doing
all right you're doing all right buddy
you're making sure yeah you don't have
any payments for tax companies we got
money yeah yeah
so what'd you do with the car
oh this is the you didn't get to the
what was the hardest part for me
uh i needed to know that that kelly was
gonna be 100 on board with this uh but
when she said we had two beautiful cars
her car was nice too and she said i have
to sell the car and my car yeah when she
said that i was like man she's serious
uh and so i traded in my beautiful
mercedes for a honda civic atta boy
that i still drive
and when he did that i was like oh shoot
i better
take this seriously because he just gave
up
yeah both of them what were you driving
a toyota highlander
before i was driving a ford expedition
it was so big and beautiful
and expensive they're both they're both
grieving these cars
still hurt
look how tightly he's holding his hands
by the car he's just really good cars
though they were very nice reasonable to
grieve those cars yeah yeah wow way to
go guys
so there
something happens when you
start extracting stuff like that out of
your life
uh it reshapes your heart doesn't it
yeah it's like do you
do we want to live for cars or character
you know
i want to be known for my character not
for this mercedes we drive that we don't
even own so it was a big big change i'm
gonna drive a civic and buy other
people's lunch
you guys y'all touched on something that
happens a lot when two great people who
are well-meaning
you paid off something big to help out
everybody and ended up embarrassing you
at work and you work really hard and
we're working a side shift to help the
family and so you're going past each
other even though you're you're great
people you love each other you're just
missing each other the night there's
something about getting on this budget
together and saying let's do this
together that maximizes everything right
absolutely you have to be a team so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of dennis
i think it's contentment and
self-control like to know that
what we have is enough oh you went
existential on honest man double
counseling
so yeah i feel like it's it is it is
i completely agree yeah i would say it
took teamwork
and a budget i mean you can't
underestimate how important having a
budget is that you stick to yeah uh and
teamwork i mean the these four sitting
over here gave up just as much as we did
yeah and uh at a time in life where they
had gotten used to enjoying things yeah
have to give it up was tough yeah four
teenagers that you do a money ectomy on
that's tough yeah they were super good
about it to get dropped off at the dance
in the mercedes than the accord huh
they felt it they felt it you know what
the hardest thing with that was at work
i mean i work in healthcare and i've
seen that change from cars in the
parking lot and all five of the changes
i saw were all divorces so people
started asking that question you're like
no no kelly and i are great we love each
other like i'm still married that's not
what's going on here i think i divorced
was a mercedes yeah yeah but another
level of like you know embarrassment and
kept you know nose down get it done yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely that's a ban
and now you never have to think about it
again
yeah yeah praise the lord no it's funny
that's funny it's great pretty cool very
cool and you'll have had the moments
where you've been this has been a few
months ago so you've had the moments
where you get to keep all of your own
money yeah that's when i'm like wow
it's going to be okay yeah yeah it's
going to be okay yeah it was worth it it
was worth it yeah
i had one child who asked me i won't
point them out but uh when is this
budget thing going to be over
it's like
they felt it too you know and it's like
oh this is because the same one was with
the booth right yes same one who asked
me if she we could stop and get
something and i broke because i had been
telling them no for months and um she
said you know what mom if it's not in
the budget we can wait we're almost done
i was like yeah you go girl yeah i like
it yeah
well you've changed your family tree
then
so many ways so very very well done
all right we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you because if you're
not already you will be soon
now that you've done all of this very
well done and a copy total money
makeover for you to give away to someone
else and let's bring the kiddos up uh
and have them participate in the process
the uh the young men and women there you
know it's not kiddos by any stretch of
the imagination but uh good job you guys
very proud of you guys you're an
incredible family very well done and
you've changed everything yeah you've
changed everything the grandkids the
grandkids are changed and they're not
even here yet yeah this is great i love
it all right joe and kelly mackenzie
isaac olivia and hayley from new york
178 000 paid off a mercedectomy
did it in 19 months making uh 260 to 300
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream ready three
two one we're dead three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls
yep
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america this is common sense for your
life for your mental wellness
for your money
for your relationships it all runs
together with your job your career it
all is intermingled
daniel is in new york hi daniel welcome
to the ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
um i'd like to say congrats to the last
people that were debt-free too yeah
that's great
thank you
um i've got a i got a fun question i i
got my mole compass kind of going crazy
so yeah my wife and i are on
step two
and my grandparents um have recently
passed away
um they had a will made back thank you
very much they had a will made
made in the 80s um and then they had it
updated
after
my mother passed away and i had an aunt
pass away so they had five kids
um and the second will is not valid so
they're reverting to the original will
which had all five kids in the will but
now two of the two of the children are
gone
i have two brothers so
the three of us brothers would be
entitled to one of the five shares
basically of the estate correct my
my moral compass question comes into
the second will they had made that's not
valid there was an issue with
witnesses or whatever
but that will stated that
the estate goes to the three remaining
children
so so they would have could they would
have cut you out
right right i wouldn't have been part of
that why well it wasn't well they
weren't trying to cut out the grandkids
what they were trying to do
is they did while they were living
well
but there was there's a lot more
grandkids involved and they think they
were trying to remove
um preferential treatment oh they
weren't cutting you out they were
cutting out the two they shut out his
mom's share and gave it to her brothers
and sisters uh he went from a five share
to a three share right
right in the will that didn't happen but
i mean we're trying to find out what
grandma and grandpa were thinking
because that's where your moral compass
is spinning from right
correct correct so what's your question
so i mean i could renounce this
like you know i could renounce my share
and kind of follow their wishes
and basically give my share to the other
aunts and uncles
but do i do that or do i just
keep it and throw it toward
all my
you know working on my debt
i don't know why you have an obligation
to renounce this
you didn't cause any of this
so your morals are not in question
you're just rece on the receiving end of
a screwed up mess
right if
the people involved or
the actions uh
were
uh
if they were doing something and you
didn't want the money because of what
they were doing like they were engaged
in
i don't know uh
do they were engaged in something that
you thought was immoral and they made
money from that and you didn't want that
money
that that would be a moral reason for
you to renounce it but this is you this
is just a screwed up and legal
entanglement and it's it's kind of all
been settled it sounds like
uh well we're a long ways from that
where
we
i've got to sign some paperwork to do
some probate things and some other
lawyer forms and it's going to be have
you been many months away do you have
family members who are calling you out
who are challenging you no no this is so
my aunt is the executor of the estate
um and i trust her you know 100 with my
life and everything else
she's just letting us know what's going
on
we have to so myself and my two brothers
have to sign some paperwork because my
mom is one of the one of the kids that
passed away yeah yeah so we have to
sign paperwork for the lawyers to say
yes we're yeah
we're the descendants yeah
yeah i i don't i don't i don't i do not
see a moral dilemma
okay
um because
and the second part of that is i also
i'm still confused as to what the flip
your grandparents were trying to pull
off with the second wheel it doesn't
even it's not logical
it doesn't make sense
it sounds like they didn't think it
through very well
because basically they were going to
give your aunts and uncles all the money
and cut out the two children that had
the heirs of the two children that had
died and that's not logical unless
somebody did something wrong and they
wanted to cut them out
but the effect of that second will that
was that was determined to be invalid
was that you were cut out your mom was
cut out
your mom's share was cut out
right
yeah maybe it's god working his way back
in yeah i just it doesn't make sense i
think they just screwed up
not only did they screw up on the i
really think your grandparents didn't
even realize what they were doing
probably is what it sounds like to me
because i mean unless there's somebody
your aunt says you know
well you know
there's no logic flow to this
you know unless some unless you were
trying to
carve out a particular branch because of
misbehavior or they just didn't want the
money for the grandkids they just wanted
for kids and i'm just going to give my
kitten yeah but that cuts out their dead
children's grandkids yeah yeah kids
that's just not logical yeah it doesn't
make sense
so um but it's okay you can do whatever
you want to do with your money you're
allowed to and
it's just i i think your grandparents
were
were dizzy
and you know and then that's part of
what made the wheel invalid was that
they didn't they didn't follow through
on that part right because here's the
thing if they sat down with an attorney
attorney would have said what are you
doing just making sure you understand
well this is what you're doing yeah and
then it would have been properly
notarized and properly witnessed instead
they just bought this thing over at home
they bought the wheel kit at home depot
or something and you know and then did
the thing instead of doing a proper will
with you know that's why with mama bear
legal forms we tell you to go there you
get a state specific will and each state
has unique laws some somewhat unique
laws potentially and witnesses are very
different in some states
some states don't require a witness some
states require four some require one
some require notarization some don't
and so you need those exact steps in the
state that you reside in when you die
and that's why we use your mama bear
legal form so you get the thorough and
the will is actually valid then
so in your case daniel i i appreciate
that you're open-handed with this and
you're compassionate towards your uncles
and aunts and you you're noble enough to
want your grandparents wishes to go
forward but i'm personally a little bit
confused about your grandparents wishes
i don't know what they were trying to
accomplish i kind of think they're dizzy
i think they were dizzy and so i'm not
worrying about this i'm signing the
papers let's just go forward i'm not
gonna be mad about it if it doesn't work
out but as long as it just keeps going
this way i'm gonna go this way
and let it unfold and it just is what it
is
so hey thanks for the call that's an
interesting discussion
john it is so important for every adult
to have a will
a valid will gosh man i ca i just can't
think of a
more
childish way to be a grown-up than to
not have a will
and yet 78 of the people listening to us
don't have a will there is zero
correlation that if you fill out a will
it means you're going to die soon
there's a hundred percent correlation
that if you fill out a will you care
about your family
and your estate even if you don't think
you have much of an estate
not dragging your poor family through
the court systems and through the weird
cousin that comes out of the woods and
all the stuff
man just and i did it i
i don't want to push something i don't
use i got mama bear will and did mine
families and it's quick
and it's not painful
it is painful because you're discussing
your death it's awkward and weird my
dad's a homicide detective that ship
sealed to my house but for my friends i
mean
it is it is for most people it is
awkward and weird right i mean we have
the ramsey estate meeting once a year
and we tell
tickets to
we should because it's like a monty
python meeting i'm feeling much better
it's just a flesh wound but yeah it's
like we discussed dave's death
thoroughly for a couple of hours once a
year you go with me there you gotta do
it you gotta do it it's weird but yeah
so what's going to happen if he dies
this year i'm here i'm here don't talk
about me in the third person yeah but
yeah but it's just the whole thing but
you got to do it guys it's diligence
it's saying i love you having life
insurance to take care of your wife your
kids your husband your kids
your dog your whatever loving life
insurance
is vital having a will
that's valid
and that everyone knows where it is that
your family knows where it is ah jeez
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delonie co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones as we talk about your
relationships your mental wellness your
boundaries your job your career and your
money we talk about all of it right here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ian is going to
start us off in guam hi ian how are you
good morning gentlemen half a day um
i'm doing well i was hoping that you and
john could help me today answering this
question um
currently in babysit 46
we have a paid off car our family is
growing and
i'm trying to find out how do we upgrade
a vehicle uh without going back into
debt and especially with this time but
but how do we do that
well i think you know
you have to save the money
yes so how do you get how do you save
the money i mean what is your income
uh currently about 90 000. that's good
so what is your current car worth
uh about it's estimated between 11 to 15
trade-in 11 to 15 is a pretty good range
so we probably can get 15 in this
current world that we live in okay so
let's call it 15. what are you upgrading
to what what kind of price range car
would you buy
so upgrading from a corolla to hopefully
a full-size suv
just with the amount of stuff that we
have
we're traveling the rest of you're doing
travel nursing so
um we're trying to go back to this how
much money
uh
currently saved up
no how much will the suv cost
about
25 to 35 that's our rank our budget is
25 35 so we're looking you don't have a
budget you don't have any money
you have a budget once you've got a
money right
yes okay well let's call it 25.
if you sell yours for 15 and you're
gonna buy an suv for 25 you need 10
you make 90. how long does it take to
get 10 when you make 90.
pretty quick okay
that's how you do it
okay
i mean that was like some pin and teller
style magic right there dude
so brother where are you where are you
getting stuck something that that that
seems yeah
yeah i know i know it sounds it sounds
pretty silly no no i'm with you man i've
gotten stuck too just where are you
stuck what's what's what's messing with
you you got car fever for a car you
can't afford you want to go buy it today
is that what's missing with you
um no it's just that um
our car is all the way in on the other
other side in maryland and we're trying
to
go you know closer to like washington or
why but
my dilemma is we have to you know some
one of us will have to go in and trade
it in
or we can do online and it's just the
hassle of should we do online i should
just go back in person trade it in
because that's just you know a headache
for us as far as trying to upgrade and
using a vehicle you don't have a vehicle
in guam
right
correct sorry what was that you don't
have a car in guam right
we're renting a car okay
your military i'm guessing
no travel nursing travel nursing okay so
you're renting a car in guam how long
are you gonna stay in guam
until july okay
and so getting a car in guam is gonna
cause a problem because you can turn
around and get rid of it right
or you're going to have to ship it
somewhere
yes and that's that's another issue that
well
it's not i'm not sure if we should keep
paying renting a car if when we move
back to the states or we should just get
our car that we have paid off where are
you going into live
uh it's up in the air right now because
it goes contract with contract so we can
decide where we want to go so we're
hoping either washington or hawaii one
of those two somewhere
but it's like it's up in the air it's
just we don't want to pay rental we
don't want to rent a car moving a car
from guam to hawaii would cost more than
the stupid car
yeah so we're not doing that right so
you're not going to buy a car that
you're going to keep for very long
if you buy a car in guam you're going to
turn right around and sell it in july
and if you wait until july somebody's
going to have a couple of three annoying
days because one of you is going to fly
out to
the east coast and deal with the car buy
a new one because you're going to have
cash by then you know what i would do
i'd keep my life real clean and real
simple you guys are making bank right
now because you're doing travel nursing
you're making you said you're making 90.
is that all i'm making between the two
of you
um no just just my wife right now oh
okay what do you do
uh i'm a financial coach with dave
ramsey actually but
um
so that's my i'm just stay at home and i
do my financial coaching
all right it's just that you need to get
on you need to get on a plane and go to
maryland and show your car
okay
and then when you get back with them
when you get back with the money you can
decide whether to buy a car in guam that
you're going to sell in july or whether
to rent from now until july and then
when you land in hawaii
uh or washington then you buy a car
got it yeah that's my plan it just took
me a minute to catch up with what was
still getting you it's a long weekend
it's an annoying weekend or three days
just get on the plane go sell your car
there's people who want to buy cars like
crazy right now there's a shortage you
can sell it in 20 minutes just you know
put it on
craigslist or trader.com or something
and go ahead and get three buyers lined
up to look at it right after you land at
the airport drive over to where it's
sitting meet them there make sure the
batteries some one of your friends went
by and charge the battery and shine the
tires and
uh sell the stupid thing get back on
plane go back home with a pocket full of
cash or have a friend who you trust that
you left the car with have them get it
detailed and then have them sell it and
tell me give them 500 bucks to the sale
yeah and be done yeah you have them for
taking care of it for you give them give
them a gift card to the steakhouse i
don't care whatever but yeah it's just
uh
what's cause what's happening here it's
not really a car problem it's that you
all aren't you haven't you don't know
where you're gonna be
and once you know where you're gonna be
it's gonna clear up all this but you
know you're not gonna be in guam past
july so you know i'm not sure you buy a
car there i think you probably it's only
a couple months let's just keep renting
it i wouldn't screw with it but i'd go
and get that other one sold because
you're not going to use it either it's
just sitting over there put the money in
your pocket and buy a car when you land
yeah that's what i am going to do i'm
going to go and take it one step further
don't buy a car in on nope absolutely
not go to the states sell your car or
have your friend do it for you one or
two like john said
and um rent until july and then when you
decide when you move to the next place
go buy a car
with cash
all right let's let's i'm going to walk
through this real quick okay okay uh we
got time for a little break
lots of variables lots of moving parts
that can be paralyzing it feels chaotic
in our heads and so we're just going ah
you're talking to a coach right that's
what he does for a living he helps other
people it just feels like a lot and what
you just did in quick form is all right
let's put all these variables down what
can i control i can sell that car i'm
gonna get on a plane it's gonna cost me
some money i'm gonna sell that car
number two i'm not gonna buy a car until
i know where i'm going number three
where we're going is is unknown cool i'm
just gonna sit with a pile of cash and
that's what i can control in this thing
and then the dust clears and let me just
tell you the the
stuck part the anxious part the stress
of all this as soon as you have your
little game plan laid out evaporates
goes away evaporates the ambivalence the
not knowing will kill you yes
you have to get a clear path start
checking boxes start walking down the
checklist before you take the airplane
off into the air it's every pilot does
that this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
here in tennessee the grass is starting
to get green the pollen is out the hay
fever is kicking in and that can only
mean one thing
real estate sales are getting ready to
get even hotter
winter breaks out spring starts to come
in how
i don't know how you can get hotter than
it has been but i think it's going to
it's going to be i mean people are back
at it man and listen if you don't want
to make listen you make a mistake uh
buying
uh dentine gum
you can survive that mistake you don't
want to make a mistake buying a house
selling a house that could be a hundred
thousand dollar 200 000 mistake don't
buy something you don't understand do
you know where you start you are are you
sure you're financially ready for a
mortgage are you confused about how the
buying process works
start by connecting with an endorsed
local provider
these are agents i trust they are ramsey
trusted our elps will help guide you
through the entire home buying or home
selling
process they're here to teach you every
step of the way so you feel confident in
this big money decision
go to ramseysolutions.com agent and you
can connect with one of our ramsey
trusted
endorsed local provider agents ramsey
solutions dot com slash
agent
shailen is in saskatchewan hi shailene
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i own a small
construction business and we are often
making
large material purchases upwards of ten
thousand dollars
so how do we do this without using
credit cards we're debt-free
personally and
with our business but where you use a
credit card to make business purchases
online and over the phone
and we don't have a problem with paying
it off but we want to get away from
credit card so what
debit card do you recommend for a large
online business purchases
you'll have to customize your debit card
with your local bank the way we have
because a large singular purchase won't
fly with most debit cards unless you've
got it set up most of them have pretty
stringent daily limits and single
purchase limits
and uh so but you can have that
customized like you know i don't walk
around with a debit card that's that's
limits me to a thousand bucks i mean i i
may buy something expensive because i've
got the money and so
obviously the relationship i have with
the bank allows me to do that and you've
got to do that with a good local bank
and set your debit card up and then
obviously you have to build up the
the uh business savings it's called
retained earnings to be able to cash
flow this on behalf of your clients
until you get the money back from them
obviously when you're ordering something
you're passing that cost on to your
customer
and you're getting the money back after
as they pay a draw on the construction
or as they pay for the construction
project being completed one of the two
right
yeah yeah so you're just it's a 30-day
thing maybe
uh and so you know you're just gonna you
need up you need to uh
prime the pump one time
if you had twenty thousand dollars cash
sitting in your business checking
account it just rolled over all the time
it would drain down some and then it
would come back up when you got paid and
then it would drain down some and then
it would come back up when you get paid
you just set a limit i don't go below 15
000 cash in my business
retained earnings because i need that
much to cash flow
these purchases and so on and so yeah it
may take you a little while to get there
uh the other thing we did because we
didn't have the money to to cover it in
the early days like that if we were
purchasing something here like
let's say we go and buy
in the old days maybe we buy 10 000
copies of a book that we're getting
ready to sell
and then we ship those books out to
bookstores and we ship them out through
the distributors and it may be two three
months before we get paid on those
and so what we had to do was just go
ahead and you know build the money up to
pay for the order period
and then when the money came back in
off of the sale of those books it was as
if we uh
as if it was all free money you know
because we didn't have anything else we
won we never owed against it you know it
was a 100 check right we'd already paid
for the cost of goods sold i already
paid for the materials i've done a few
home projects over the years where the
builder comes and says here's what your
material costs are going to be to get
out the door to get started
and they required that up front yeah and
so i actually
gave them money that way i'm not going
to walk and they're not so um and i've
heard horror stories about that where gc
can walk off with your pre-payment but i
like that option too yeah change your
terms that's what i was leading to was
on the books
we had to if somebody wanted an
unusually large order that we couldn't
cash flow we just had to require a
deposit of 50 up front and that pays for
the books and that actually paid for
more than the books it paid for some
more because we don't have 50 in them so
our cost of goods sold is not that high
and so we had to change the terms of
working with our customer but i love
that what you said about if you get 20
or 30 000 bucks in your account you
become your own bank yep and i love that
way of operating yeah and it's just it's
real clean i'll tell you the other thing
it's weird is
it it changes what you're buying and how
you're buying it
because it's like real money when you're
doing it with debt it doesn't feel like
it's real money but when you're pulling
your money out of your checking account
to make this purchase you're like uh
you have this moment where you just make
sure it's all right you measure to the
fence post yeah yeah and you don't think
about that when you're just slapping a
plastic down we gotta take over later
just get it just get it we gotta get
this going we gotta get and you get
sloppier when you're using borrowed
money
unless less wise
uh catalina is with us in new york city
hi catalina how are you
i am great how are you guys going better
than we deserve what's up
i'm so excited to talk to you guys um so
i am
just
myself and my husband we're just
starting now to try to pay off some debt
right
um and i've just started listening to
your radio show about a month ago and i
have a lease which i know was a stupid
idea
and i'm about halfway through my three
year lease
and i'm wondering if i should buy it out
or continue until i'm done and then
because if i buy it out it's it's not
going to be in cash it would be to
finance it
or should i just wait until the lease
term is
done
yeah and then um there's no reason to
buy it out with financing that doesn't
serve any purpose um right and so run it
out to the lease term is done turn the
car in make sure you're not over on your
miles you don't have excessive wear and
tear so they don't ding you again at the
turn-in
and also make sure you have the money
saved up to buy you a little car of some
kind
so you don't don't plan on financing a
car when you turn this in you got to
break this cycle
right right okay that's the big thing so
you got 18 months to get that ready will
you be debt-free except this when you do
the in within 18 months
no no no we're just starting with our
debt-free journey so we've we've just
paid off all plastic so there's no more
plastic good way to go
that felt weird didn't it
but yeah but there's still like there's
one person alone there's one student
loan and there's our mortgage so not
counting but not counting your mortgage
will you be done in 18 months
uh
probably not i think it's going to take
a little longer okay
all right well that'd be cool i mean if
if you happen to get there and then when
you turn the car in that was one of the
last few things that happened
to make you debt free except the
mortgage then that'd be a cool thing but
again you've got to plan
for the turning in of the car
make sure you're not overrunning the
miles make sure you're not doing
excessive wear and tear uh so you don't
get an extra check you have to write
when you turn the car in
um and then the uh
and make sure you've saved up some money
to get a little car of some kind and
plan for the second thing too so dave
like plan for the money part
i would almost guarantee that the car
you're leasing is gonna be nicer than
the car you're gonna be able to buy
prepare yourself for that
it often is like i'm i'm releasing this
cool lexus or this brand new whatever
and now i'm gonna buy i'm gonna buy the
previous caller for another hour i'm
gonna buy their uh used corolla from
massachusetts right
prepare yourself for that it's part of
your journey here and it's gonna feel
like you lost something you're not
you're winning no you're actually now
admitting what you really can afford
there you go instead of running acting
like you can afford more than you can
which is what debt does for you
it's a it's a form of pretending
aidan is in pueblo colorado hi aiden how
are you
oh i'm doing well how are you
doing better than i deserve hey i goofed
man i brought you up right 30 seconds
before commercial so i'm gonna put you
back on hold we're gonna come back to
you after the break and uh or as soon as
we can one of the two is there that free
after the break there's okay gonna come
back to you after this next segment
aiden so you gotta hold a little bit
longer i apologize uh i wasn't watching
the clock
goofy bad talk radio stuff here this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
grand rapids michigan rhys and courtney
are on the line it says on my screen you
guys are debt-free congratulations
hey thank you dave yeah welcome how much
did you pay off
uh we paid off uh 77
231 dollars
how long did this take
yeah over a span of 18 months 18 months
good and your range of income during
that time uh we started at around 64 000
and our kind of peak income was around
102 000. good what do you guys do for a
living
uh i work for a small computer repair
shop and uh courtney works for the for
the state of michigan health department
cool what kind of debt was your 77 000
oh it was a little bit of everything
main thing being student loans we also
had a car loan a couple of car loans in
there and credit cards
yeah wow way to go man so how long you
all been married
uh for
just under two years uh
yeah it'll be june june will be two
years so yeah so you get married come
home from the honeymoon and looked at 77
000 and went uh oh this is grown-up land
we gotta kill this what happened tell me
the story yeah so it's actually yeah so
we we saw the debt we had a you know
goals as a couple and it was like part
of our marriage goal was to pay that all
off but the first you know
i'd say probably about
six or seven months or so we weren't
like super serious
about getting after that debt it wasn't
until um
i got kind of plugged back into your
show and started listening more to the
advice and everything else and i was
like okay no there's there's a plan this
is this is doable and um
we got really serious about it so we
were doing you know just one job at
peace for a little while and then once
we're like oh let's see if we can really
go after this and that's when we both
picked up
uh multiple jobs started you know doing
whatever we could to just increase our
shovel as big as we could and that
really like
the amount of improvement we saw over
the last the tail end of that 18 months
was so much greater than the first part
there yeah so courtney this your your
new husband starts listening to this
crazy guy on the radio and he comes up
with this crazy idea that we need to
sacrifice like crazy and get out of debt
what did you think do you think he lost
his mind
no not at all i uh gosh was a bit of a
minimalist even before we were married
just trying to do what i can to make
that student loan less so i have my
master's degree which is where a lot of
my student loan came from is you know
six years of education so trying to make
that as small as i can
and it was just encouraging to see rhys
come in and just have that fire like i
think brought a lot of the momentum for
us yeah we're going to do this but now
we did it like really seriously
on our budget and so i think it was just
the momentum that kind of made that
duration to pay it off a little bit
shorter yeah that's amazing well done
what's your master's in
public health all right
uh yeah it's fitting great
a boring few years yeah
it was a good time to have it i finished
in uh 2019 and then pandemic kit and
that's kind of what was the open door to
step in congratulate it'll all be
downhill from here so congratulations
hopefully
pretty cool guys what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is
for me i'd say it's you know just
finding a plan and sticking to it so
we're very thankful to have uh
have your your plan the baby steps and
everything else um and just having that
once that was in place it was just okay
we'll
we reference this we stick to this and
then
no matter we know that no matter how
hard it gets or how like
any complications come along it's like
okay we know that the plan works we're
gonna we're just gonna stick to it and
it came it came through for us so that
was a
big deal there
who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
so we had uh thankfully plenty of people
encouraging us and helping us out
through along this way
kind of the ones who stand out the most
are
my parents uh we have some good friends
kristen kristen and kyle and uh and our
aunt linda
i also even though they weren't a part
of this particular process i want to
also give a quick shout out to my
original
uh financial financial peace university
uh leaders they even or sorry mike and
kathy uh they were you know put the
spark in me five years ago and then
since then that was the was able to
ignite that fire for getting through
this that here so definitely
haven't had lots of people those are
just uh the tip of the iceberg really
when it comes to
who were helping us out for sure
what was the what was the best
disagreement y'all had
oh that's a good question oh goodness um
i think if anything it's just
uh now just trying to figure out like
all right now that's that's paid off
like what's the next big step how do we
spend all this money that's ours right
yeah
for sure we um exciting news are
expecting a baby in september so
congratulations
thank you thank you trying to figure out
what the next goal is so you know saving
up for a house or sitting up for baby or
whatever it might be so i think that's
the most i don't know relevant thing for
right now what's the next round and
we're so thankful that we don't have
a mountain of debt to worry about in
this pro process side so it's like we
were secure in knowing that and knowing
that whatever money we have is money
that we get to put into our future yeah
it changes everything way to go you guys
very very well done very proud of you
good work good work we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too we want you to
finish the baby steps become
millionaires in the process and that's
the next chapter in your story okay
absolutely and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to someone
and get them stirred up as well so
very well done you two very well done
recent courtney grand rapids michigan 77
000 paid off in 18 months making 64 to
102. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
all right
three
two
one
we're set free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
recent courtney way to go man that's it
beautiful job
well done well done
all right as promised i'm gonna try to
get aiden in here from pueblo colorado
hi aiden welcome to the ramsey show
right on thanks for having me dave sure
i'm not going to psych you out this time
what's up how can we help
well uh so
just a little quick you know we'll make
it too long-winded here but the high
school that i graduated at i'm 23 years
old
i'm married and uh the high school that
we went to it made us take baby steps to
graduate we actually had to take your
whole your whole course and and go
through the thing and so we come out of
high school with pretty good idea stuff
and um we've had some fairly good
success in the industries that we're in
and i've got a handful of money to
invest
um and i had a you know i had some
questions on how to how to get it
invested okay how much money
hundred thousand dollars at 23 years old
yes sir well done wow way to go man mike
drop good job man yes where'd you get
that money
uh well we grew uh we grew up in a real
small town and um everybody i didn't
didn't buy cars i mean i still drive old
crappy cars and stuff and uh we found a
little property to buy that me and my
wife wanted to buy and we bought it and
then we had an industry a massive
industry boom right in our little town
no one could have expected it and we
turned a house for quite a profit
and then right after that i got into the
real estate industry and so i'm a real
estate licensee here in the state of
colorado and she's in a pretty
specialized uh commercial beekeeping
industry and we just put a bunch of
money back you know all of your stuff
the whole okay you know so do you are
you do you own the home you live in
uh no so i actually rent a home but it's
on we're on a
a river bottom ranch and i run cattle on
this ranch that pays for the house
so we don't make a lot of money on the
cows but they they
keep the house free essentially
okay so do you want to buy a home
i would like to buy a home but i would
like to invest i we we live in kind of a
funny area right now and we kind of want
to see what the way things are going to
go or if we want to stay in colorado or
what but okay well i only put money in
two things and i don't tell people to do
otherwise
you can certainly put money in whatever
you want but i buy good growth stock
mutual funds
and i buy real estate that i pay cash
for those are the two investments i do
in your situation i think you just dump
this into some mutual funds click smart
vester find the smart vista pro in your
area at ramseysolutions.com the person
we recommend for investing
and sit down with them tell them what
your goals are and they'll help you
place that money into the into some good
mutual funds with some safety
and uh you can access it anytime you
need to later for the next thing you're
going to do with it this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 3 3 let
love and faithfulness never leave you
bind them around your neck write them on
the tablet of your heart
then you will win favor and a good name
in the sight of god
and man
william arthur ward said when we seek to
discover the best in others we somehow
bring out the best in ourselves
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from cheyenne in
tennessee
shaina writes my boyfriend and i are
going to be engaged soon he knows and
agrees with my dreams of being a
stay-at-home mom and homeschooling our
children but he thinks i should
sacrifice more for our future marriage
all right
this sacrificing talk is based on him
trying to get me to move across the
country so he can go to school and
pursue a career
he had never talked about moving until
recently and he's beginning to shame me
and even called me selfish
i was raised believing it's the man's
job to leave and cleave and provide for
the family at what point does the woman
need to sacrifice if at all
good lord
you should not get engaged soon
neither one of you are ready for
marriage no not at all even close
and you're conflating
a little bit of scripture and a little
bit of folk wisdom and a little bit of
what you want to do and a little bit of
what he wants to do in a little bit of
ten years from now
and a little bit this is a mess you know
pull this sucker apart man
but at the end of the day
the idea of being a stay-at-home mom and
homeschooling and somebody's saying
that's not enough you need to do better
that's one conversation
um sacrificing like hey i got a job
right out of school and this is we're
going to live in this part of the
country for a little while and we're
going to work hard
that's like another conversation and
then the shaming each other is another
conversation and then this it's a man's
job to do that's another conversation
that you all need to have before you do
any talk about what woman does at what
point does the woman need to sacrifice
if at all
that's a 10 year old 12 year old
emotional question right
that's a little baby question right
there and
hey i know you want to be a stay-at-home
mom and homeschooling um
but you're just gonna have to sacrifice
me that's an eleven-year-old response
man this whole thing is just you guys
are no please don't get married no no
you're gonna kill each other
i mean you know you got you guys got
some work to do that's pretty serious
but it'd be fun to talk about a couple
of these things for the heck of it yeah
pick something we're kind of kind of
outside kind of outside the uh
the uh the the context of of her actual
situation which we've just you know
pretty well
you know didn't give the answer she
wanted so at what point does the woman
need to sacrifice if at all
i don't know
where you get this idea that both of you
don't sacrifice for the rest of your
lives
you serve one another
uh
the bible says submit yourselves one to
another yeah and so if you're gonna be
selfish and sit over here like a little
princess on a little throne and say the
woman doesn't have to sacrifice the man
is supposed to work and bring me stuff
and you know this is this is just not
marriage material and that's really what
that sounded like when i heard it yeah
but i read it i i went after him
thinking i'm gonna go after him too i'm
not done
yeah
this this idea of sacrifice it should be
a race
so who can raise the other one to the
bottom how can i out serve if you do
that if you live like that and she lives
like that your marriage will be the
greatest of anyone you know yeah and
you're going exactly the opposite
direction both of you what's the least
amount i can do and get by with the
rules so listen if if your daughter
shyanna comes to you
in 15 or 20 years
hopefully 20 plus years from today the
daughter that you don't yet have
um comes to you and she's 20 years old
and says her
soon-to-be fiance is shaming her
what would you tell her i know what i
would tell one of my daughters run right
and what's his address i know some guys
yeah i can help him with his shaming
so um
we have a hillbilly answer for that but
yeah but the uh uh
you know he's shaming you and you think
that's and then you and we're about to
be engaged soon and this is how he
handles our conflicts right you know
because he's a little boy and he's
throwing a little fit on the cereal
aisle and says well you should just do
whatever i want to do because i'm the
man
and i'm like well you're not a man
though you're a little boy
in a man's body
and the way
so i we were we were living in texas i
lived there my whole life and then i got
an incredible opportunity i had a couple
of colleagues that were over at this
wonderful school called belmont we
talked to him and then i sat down with
sheila and said hey there's this
potential opportunity here she could
have said
you never talked about moving before
this thing's dead
or she could have said tell me more
about this and i would have said here's
the career part here's the family part
there's this part and she would say oh
that's exciting let me get involved in
this and let's let's think this through
and talk this through yeah one of those
is about us and one of this is about me
and it sounds like both of the i can
only speak to the author it sounds like
the author has a picture of her life
that she has already mapped out and that
she is waiting for some guy to show up
and make it all happen and that's not
how marriages work period that's how
life works man life goes sideways on us
yeah
so i'll teach you to write us an email
just
attach them to the whipping post man
it's just like
uh
but hey guys this is um
yeah the language is all there and it's
none of it good all right jennifer is in
tallahassee florida hi jennifer welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you john and dave for taking my
call sure what's up um and i have a
question about staying home and
homeschooling that's okay we won't shame
you
i'm a huge fan we won't shame you watch
this this is how it's done dude from
tennessee
all right go for it
okay so we're on baby steps um four five
and six um my husband and i are 40 and
42. um and
we decided that i should quit my job
i've been homeschooling for the past
nine years
but i have worked part time for
almost all of those nine years
and you're gonna drop the part-time job
i'm just gonna drop the part-time job
how much were you making at a kind of a
bad job um next to nothing i make about
twenty thousand a year and they pay me
okay so he makes 140 you used to make 20
and now you don't
whoopi you're okay
are you worried about the identity part
you're gonna lose yourself
yeah because i've been a teacher for um
about 20 years
and i've been working at this private
school and the pay has been terrible and
the work's been terrible and just the
entire job has been super stressful
um
but still all i've done it was your
identity to be a teacher and you did
have a place where you got to
you had to you had to shower you had to
show up to and you got to meet with
other adults and i what i hear folks
when they
when women say i'm gonna quit my job i'm
gonna stay home for a season
there's this identity loss because i was
of this i was a teacher i was of this
and now i'm just a
so it's important when you make this
transition to have a group of friends
that you're gonna hang out with
regularly at once twice a week a group
of girlfriends you're gonna hang out and
you're gonna have to work hard to shift
into a new identity what that's gonna
look like i think financially dave i
think they're fine financially
what was your question
in retirement yeah so what are you
worried about
um that are not contributing um you know
we've always
we've always tried to just but ever
since we were first married just live on
my husband's income and put mine towards
you know first it was towards the house
down payment and you know then it was
towards you know going towards the kids
college funds and hey jennifer
you guys can make it on 140 kid the
greatest contribution you can give to
this your family is to be well
take care of yourself quit working at a
crappy place that underpays you and
doesn't value you
be whole take care of your kids
partner up with your husband that's the
greatest contribution you give to your
family right now you're going to be just
fine you'll be just absolutely well done
good choice
good choice that puts us hour of the
ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you